Howard Gardner author of extraordinary
minds where did you get the idea for
this book
I've been studying extraordinary people
for about 15 or 20 years and I've done
careful studies of at least 25 or 30 and
then I actually got an invitation to
write a short book which sort of
summarized my recent thinking and I said
let me see if I can pull it all together
and talk about what the rest of us might
learn from people who are sufficiently
extraordinary were unlike you to be just
like them what do you call extraordinary
I have a fairly simple definition a
person is extraordinary to the extent
that he or she really changes the way
work goes on in a certain domain so if
your next ordinary scientists a
physicist physics is different after
Einstein if you're an extraordinary
composer say like Stravinsky or the
Beatles music is different after you so
it's leaving an impact on on your
culture maybe on other cultures as well
that's what makes a person extraordinary
and you pick for extraordinary people
for this book who are they they are
Mozart composer Sigmund Freud the
psychoanalyst Virginia Woolf the British
novelist and Mahatma Gandhi who I often
say my kids think has been Kingsley
because that's how most of us see Gotti
buddy of course the great Indian
religious and political leader in this
book put out by basic books in the very
beginning of it says that this is
something called the mastermind series
what is that the idea the mastermind
series was to ask people who are
scholars to write something that's
relatively brief this book's fewer than
200 pages and synthetic that rather than
being a whole new line of work that kind
of summarizes the work that the scholar
has done over the past however many
years or decades and it's the second
series it's a series called science
masters which focuses particularly on
work in biology physics that kind of
area and this is masterminds is more
general my close colleague and high
Csikszentmihalyi who has written about
flow has one of the first books in this
series sherry Turkle a computer analyst
of especially how people redefine
themselves in terms of computers is
another person in the series but you
mentioned basic books and the last
series has to go on beyond basic books
because that publishing house
longer exists what was your reaction
when you heard that they were going to
kill her
I was actually in Washington DC on May
21st which was the day that the book
extraordinary minds was published and I
picked up the newspaper in there in the
Washington Post had said HarperCollins
folds basic books I was shocked but
nowadays what's called serious trade
publishing is having difficulty in one
way in which conglomerates deal with
that is they put to rest divisions which
they think aren't making enough money I
happen to think it was a foolish
decision than the other hand I've had
eleven books with basic books so I'm not
a disinterested party and of those
eleven what's the most general book
you've written for the most general
audiences the book that's best known as
a book called frames of mind the
subtitle is the theory of multiple
intelligences that came out in 1983 and
in that book I was one of the first
people to take the idea of intelligence
as measured by the IQ test and says this
doesn't make sense
it may predict certain things about
school but if you think about all the
things that the human mind can do and
all the ways in which people can be
extraordinary the IQ test doesn't
scratch the surface and in that book
frames of mind I described seven
different kinds of human intelligence
and we've had some inflation since then
so we now talk about eight and a half
different intelligence that's probably
the book that's best-known but my
blessing or curse is that I like to
write about different topics so I've
written about the arts I've written
about cognitive science written a lot
about education written about human
development my first book was about
structuralism Piaget and Levy Straus so
I've covered the waterfront in my books
where do you teach I teach at Harvard I
teach in a school of education I teach
what's called human development which is
basically child development learning
intelligence how can we take what's been
learned about the human mind and help us
to have kids who learn better and thrive
in school how long have you been there
I've actually at Harvard for over 30
years but I started there as an
undergraduate in the 60s and then went
through the whole regime of graduate
student researcher and then for the last
dozen years as a professor in the
education school so I'm an old-timer of
all the extraordinary minds you've
written about or thought about who would
you like to meet well I wrote a book
called on
creating mines and in there I looked at
seven people who in a sense remade the
consciousness in this century people who
are outstanding in in different domains
like like Einstein and Freud and I must
say of the people whom I studied in that
book the person who I found personally
most fascinating was Stravinsky the
composer but I asked myself the question
you just asked myself and I realized
that Stravinsky would probably have had
absolutely no use for me at all and so
the question of who you'd like to meet
it's a question of whether you think you
could have a relationship with them
I'm Stalin somebody who I studied in a
book about leadership is certainly a
fascinating individual and we wonderful
to have been able to occupy his mind for
a period of time but another hand again
and even if you forget about the
language and culture barriers you know
the fact that he might want to hang
around a intellectual who studies people
is not very very likely go back to Igor
Stravinsky who was he Stravinsky is the
person early in the century who
essentially undid music which we would
call melodic or harmonic he did this
through a series of works written in the
second decade and particularly a work
called the Rite of Spring which I think
people can now listen to without going
nuts in part because it was one of the
themes and Disney's Fantasia of the
1940s but at the time when the Rite of
Spring was plated struck people as being
so dissonant so jarring it almost seemed
like a cruel joke and Stravinsky and the
audience was pelted with the literal and
figurative tomatoes and cabbages and so
on but while classical music has never
become completely atonal which was not
what Stravinsky was striving to do
anyway the notion that you didn't have
to stay in a certain key and use kind of
a classical symphonic form is really I
think do more to Stravinsky than anybody
else but my fascination with him is not
only that I loved his music but he was a
real cosmopolitan intellectual knew
everybody had relationships with all
sorts of fantastic people grew up in
Russia at the end of the nineteenth
century who was rimsky-korsakov one of
the great composers that time then
because he was a so-called white
rushon he had to go to Western Europe
during the war in fact I don't think he
went back to Russia very late in his
life because it was the Soviet Union and
he was not welcome there
he spent the 40s in Hollywood where he
actually wrote some music for her movies
and for theater and became more pop
though there's there's a good there's a
great story about that he wrote a piece
which was probably somewhat popular and
Billy Rose who was at that time the
great showman an impresario said your
your your piece is a great success it
could be even a greater success if you
allow instrumentation by Richard Rodney
Bennett who was the arranger for the
Boston Pops and took stuff it was sort
of class we made more popular in Pskov
insky wired back am satisfied with great
success meaning don't you touch my work
he in the in the 50s when he was already
60 or 70 I think this is another reason
why I'm so fascinated by Stravinsky he
became an atonal composer he had a young
friends man still alive named Robert
Kraft too introduced him to music which
he'd always been interested in but had
been afraid of touching because it was
by his great rival Arnold Schoenberg but
Chern Berg died in 1951 and somehow it
was safe for Stravinsky so at a time
when most people are belonging to the
AARP he began to write in a wholly new
idiom and some of his works that he
wrote in his seventies and eighties are
still being being performed today so I
think it's the combination of the many
worlds that he lived in touched and the
fact that he was such a livewire and
Kraft has a whole series of books called
conversations with Stravinsky where you
really get a feeling that this guy
missed nothing what years did he live he
was born in 1882 and died in 1971 was
buried in Venice which was the city he
loved the most he didn't but he didn't
make extraordinary minds because Mozart
is even a more extraordinary composer
and he's the one I chosen to chose to
write about in this most recent book
politicians had there been many that you
studied that have extraordinary minds
well I I include in my notion of
extraordinary Minds people who have
tremendous influence without compelling
obedience and if you have a tyrant
Hitler or Stalin who makes you do
something then in a sense there do you
know they're just leveraging you by
their sheer power I'm very interested in
people who through their persuasiveness
and through the way they live had that
kind of influence and Gandhi for me is
he's not only the most remarkable man of
the century I think in some ways he may
be the most remarkable man of the
millennium because Gaudi had no weapons
didn't even have a full suit of clothing
but by simply believing so deeply that
people could dispute without destroying
one another that in fact they could be
strengthened both sides under dispute by
putting forth what they believed and
willing to take the consequences
including jailing and maybe even being
killed I think he set an incredible
moral example and as far as I'm
concerned that's an extraordinary mind
if you look not only in India today
which remains a democracy after 50
tumultuously ears but you look at the
civil rights movement in America you
look at the various political movements
in China in Russia and you think about
Nelson Mandela these are all individuals
who I think were in a way made possible
by Gandhi and his his example so that's
a politician who I put right up there
with the great religious leaders for the
past Buddha Christ Muhammad Moses
Mahatma Gandhi how do you know he had an
extraordinary mind because I think he
was able to go to fundamentals and one
of the hardest things in the world
particularly in the in the flux of daily
life is to be able to see clearly what
the forces are and what needs to be done
to change something to kind of get rid
of all the thickets in the shrubbery I
mean here was a guy who was born in
India and fairly obscure part of India
was not at all worldly in his background
defying everybody in his own circle he
went to England like he was told don't
bother to come back and he learned how
to be a lawyer there they went to South
Africa for 25 years came back to India
when he was about 50 so you can see how
much different kinds of experiences he
had in his in his life and this is at a
time when it wasn't very mobile and he
came back to India and his Nehru his
followers said he psychoanalyzed the
nation which would include in this
particular case Britain because Britain
is very much part of the indian psyche
and he figured out what it would take to
essentially impress the british and the
world that the continual colonization of
india by the british just didn't didn't
make sense and even though of course
there was some bloodshed there was
infinitely less bloodshed and they would
have been without gandhi and that's a
reason i compared with mandela because
very few of us would have thought even
as recently as ten years ago that there
could be a relatively peaceful
transition in south africa and when
nelson mandela was sworn in as president
he had sitting in his the first row his
jailer this is a quintessential Gandhian
move it's a move of forgiveness it says
we were enemies we had very very
different views of things things are not
going to improve unless we can bury the
hatchet the kind of thinking which we
haven't had in the Middle East for a
long time and you might say well in a
sense that's that's very simplistic or
you say it's the Golden Rule which means
at least simple but what Gandhi did is
he built an organization and he actually
build a kind of an algebra by which I
mean he didn't just say you know we're
gonna do this and either it's gonna work
or not
he thought through every possible
consequence of his going on a hunger
strike for example he wouldn't go on a
hunger strike who there wasn't a
telegraph around because he knew that
the word of this hunger strike had to go
all around the world so people would
pressure you know the British so you
might say he was a master military
strategist without having an army except
an army of human beings his what going
around half-naked was quite deliberate
it was saying this is what I am a human
being you may have guns you may be able
to yeah she wouldn't kill everybody but
but morally you'll be bankrupt however
we have to say at the same time gadi
chose his enemies shrewdly during the
beginning of the Second World War he
wrote letters to Hitler trying to say
you know we'll forgive me for just a
nice guy Hitler I think I write in the
book that Hitler's response has not
recorded but of course there are certain
people who would just laugh at that kind
of thing on the other hand I guess if if
India had been had belonged to
Germany and Gandhi had given himself the
same task would have gone about in a
very very different way when was Gandhi
at his peak performance when they have
the most followers and how do was it
demonstrate he talked about at one point
where he had you know I took off on a
couple hundred mile hike and had two
miles of people behind him yeah I think
mostly would say that in the last year's
of his time in South Africa in the first
years of his time in India which would
be roughly from 1910 to 1930 he really
had a power of of galvanizing people and
of embodying his own message in the way
he lived
which just put people absolutely all of
him I think as he as he got older some
of his ideas were fussier and in the
sense events took him over
I mean events took over nonetheless when
he was almost 80 before he was
assassinated still the only person in
India who could bring rival factions
which at that time was the muslims and
the hindus together again so his moral
authority didn't wane but i think his
his agility and at the prime of his life
would probably have been most striking
them in that win that 20 year period but
but but one of the things Brian about
extraordinary individuals is that they
tend not to be flashes in the pan they
tend not to you know do something once
or twice and then sink into obscurity in
fact it's the regularity of their
accomplishments and and when they're
defeated they just keep right on going
that's what really striking so I think
when I when I when I think about
extraordinary people and someone says
well did they have periods of down the
answers of course but are there long
periods when they didn't do anything the
answer is usually no Freud one of the
people I studied said when inspiration
doesn't come to me I go halfway to meet
it meaning he was going to be there
thinking and reading and writing even if
he didn't have the inspiration which
he'd like to have you said in the
beginning that you've studied what
twenty-five people up close yeah how
many of those are American politicians
when when we when you talk about
politicians attentive depends x2 extent
and how broad the definition is i've
studied both franklin roosevelt and in
ronald reagan and they certainly are
politicians but alice has studied people
like george marshall who is one of the
most extraordinary americans of the
century the he was not only the chief of
the Army during the Second World War but
both Secretary of State and Secretary of
Defense after the war and I think he was
a man of incredible achievement also a
man of incredible rectitude he wasn't a
politician in the sense that he he ran
for office I studied Alfred Sloan who
was the most important person in the
making of General Motors again I
wouldn't want to call him a political
type and you know and in those days I
used to say what was good for General
Motors was good for the country so there
was a kind of identification between
General Motors in the country which we
might now analogize to the computer
industry particularly in the heyday of
Microsoft what are some of the
characteristics of George Marshall well
one very interesting one which I wasn't
expecting at all was that he was a man
who was really quite reserved not at all
flamboyant not at all confrontational
when you met him and yet from early on
in life when he saw something which he
thought was wrong or didn't make sense
he would speak up about it he showed a
willingness to confront Authority and
even to risk his own stature in doing so
which turns out to be a marker of
extraordinary people in general
now if I told you it was it was a marker
say of Hitler or Lenin that wouldn't
surprise you because there's obviously
people who thrived on confrontation but
when someone like Marshall who was seen
as being as it were above this fray when
he - first time he met General Pershing
who was the head of the forces in the
first world war and Marshall was quite
young at that time he told him off and a
few months later Marshall Marshall was
actually hired by Pershing to be his own
chief and then the first time that
Marshall met Franklin Roosevelt which
was 15-20 years later he marshal of
course was well in middle age by that
time he told Roosevelt off
cabinet meeting and after the meeting
Henry Morgenthau who was Secretary of
Treasury went up to Marshall and sort of
said in a empathic way nice knowing you
George because you didn't confront
Franklin D Roosevelt in the first public
meeting in front of a cabinet and the
same thing happened happened with
Pershing a few months later Marshall was
offered to be the chief of staff of the
army and so I think that one very
striking feature not only of Marshall
but extraordinary people in general is
they analyze the situation they
empathize to a certain extent with the
person who's an authority and they say
hey you haven't got it right you ought
to be taking account of this now
obviously if they're too fresh if
they're too in-your-face or if they're
dealing with someone who can't take
criticism they can be finished I mean I
wouldn't speak up to Sodom who's saying
if I if I didn't see things the same way
that he did but if there's someone who
you can gauge as being open to to that
kind of thing it's a way of making a
very big impact on him and a funny thing
is in studying highly creative
individuals people whom we would think
of as being artists or scholars I first
thought well those people are not
confrontational because in fact they
don't typically tell off their their
teachers maybe or even their parents but
I realized that was a superficial
reading in fact what the the creators of
the Einstein Freud Picasso Martha Graham
type is they tell off their teachers and
mentors through the work that they do
I mean Einstein writes about relativity
and he essentially blows all of his
professors out of the water because it's
a tally different way of thinking about
the the physical world so I make a
distinction between indirect leaders or
indirect extraordinary individuals who
the details of whose life are not
important but whose work is directly
challenging the way we were talking
about Stravinsky Stravinsky basically
said you know western music doesn't have
to be the way does is you have to be
able to sing it and stick and stick and
to it can be very very different rhythm
assonance can be the the essence of
music they do their confrontation
through the work whereas political types
tend to do it through face-to-face
confrontation the interesting to think
about Gingrich and Clinton and in that
respect I think Clinton is somebody who
is face will be avoided
face to face challenges in his life
gingrich seems to be somebody who has
thrived on it though i perhaps more so
when he is doing the challenging than
when he's when he's being challenged but
those are those are different kinds of
leadership styles are they extraordinary
minds i would say at this point no when
i say at this point one of the things
about being a historian as i am is that
it's nice to have a few decades passed
so you can see the impact of individuals
a good comparison i would say would be
Gregan and thatcher i think at the time
when they were leaders they were seen as
being fairly similar and is trying to
bring about the same things in their
nations i think 100 years from now
reagan will be a footnote in history I
think Margaret Thatcher will be a very
important person but I think that
becomes clearer with time my own guess
is that the flaws of both Clinton and
Gingrich suffice to make them not know
not extraordinary but I'm prepared to be
to be wrong why will Margaret Thatcher
be more extraordinary than Ronald Reagan
because I think that um Margaret
Thatcher not only did the kind of
analysis of what was wrong in Britain by
her lights and what needed to be done to
change it but she was absolutely
persistent in pushing that program
moreover the way in which she lived the
term I used the way in which she
embodied her story or her message was
very very compelling I think that Reagan
was not as consistent and I think his
own life in a sense in a way wasn't a
strong an argument for what he was
trying to bring about as as Thatcher's
were also I think Reagan in many ways
politico's politically above the fray
which Margaret Thatcher wasn't and a
good way for Americans who aren't
necessarily very close to this
comparison to think about it is that
both Reagan and Thatcher up and out of
office for the same period of time in
the most recent elections in America
Reagan has not even mentioned he's not a
factor in the most recent election in
Britain which was in May of 97 Thatcher
was still a major person around whom
both Tony Blair and John Major based
their face their campaigns I think she
really defined issues whereas I think
Reagan
Sene part of a movement which goes back
to Goldwater which Gingrich and his crew
currently about yeah a general shift to
the to the right
I think Reagan is a good emblem of it
but I don't think that that that
personally has either his analytic
powers or his ability to to built an
organization compares with that of
Margaret Thatcher is there a difference
between being extraordinary mind being
an extraordinary person I think that yes
I think that there is when I'm talking
about extraordinary minds I'm talking
about people who by virtue of some kind
of analysis some kind of thinking bring
about a change in a domain now I have a
very broad notion of thinking a broad
notion of intelligence so to me you
don't have to be able to do it in words
some of my most creative individuals do
it through works of art I think you
could have an extraordinary mind as an
athlete I don't think that's the norm
and certainly you could be - yeah the
best weightlifter or shot put her in the
world but if you did it like everybody
else I don't think you would count as
extraordinary if however you were able
to analyze what it took to be a
weightlifter or a shot putter and I'm
talking about something I haven't don't
have any first-hand experience and and
really people from then on would do it
differently because of an insight you
had and what it took to be really good
the way say roger bannister analyzed
what it meant to run the first
four-minute mile then i think i would
include you under the extraordinary mine
so in a sense your your understanding of
what you're doing and what is deficient
in the current practice and how it has
to be changed I think would be it would
be very vital I think maybe a good way
to think about it would be heavyweight
heavyweight boxers obviously to be a
heavyweight boxer you've got to be very
strong and be able to pack a good wallet
however there are certain heavyweight
boxers who in one way or another really
change the nature of the domain
I think Muhammad Ali probably both
because of the way he fought but also
because of the kind of persona he had
really did affect boxing for a while we
might say that the the King Tyson duo
now are affecting it in a way which is
probably less desirable from the point
of view of those who care about about
heavyweight fighting when did you first
get interested in all this as a
youngster I loved biography and film
eyes out my life I've always been
interested in reading biographies
both fictionalized versions and of
course real biographies and
autobiographies but I think I would
never have actually moved into it
analytically if if two things hadn't
happened first of all as a student many
years ago and at college I was where at
Harvard College I was lucky enough to
study with Eric Erickson who was a great
psychoanalyst a student of Freud and who
himself had studied some extraordinary
people including as it happens Gandhi
but other people like Eleanor Roosevelt
Woodrow Wilson Joan of Arc people who
were what he called ideological
innovators so the notion that one could
study people's life systematically was
part of my own training but for 20 years
I was sort of a typical laboratory
researcher I worked with children with
brain-damaged adults trying to
understand the nature of their of their
cognition and it was out of that
empirical work as a so-called the bench
topper lab scientist that I became
convinced that the notion of
intelligence as being a single thing
which people either have or doesn't
couldn't be right and I developed a
notion instead of there being these
different kinds of intelligences like
linguistic intelligence spatial
intelligence musical intelligence
interpersonal intelligence and the like
having done that study of intelligence a
lot of people said to me and I also said
to myself well what does this have to
say about creativity if there is if
there isn't a single kind of
intelligence because people are
intelligent different ways I mean Reagan
was often written off as being dumb but
that's because he wasn't intelligent in
the way that most people in Washington
seem to put in the pedestal I would call
the legal kind of mind but he had plenty
of other kinds of intelligence which is
why I think he was an effective though
not an extraordinary leader so I said
well if there's different kinds of
intelligences maybe there's different
kinds of creativity so I decided to
study people who had very different
strengths and different intelligences
people like Einstein who had what I call
logical mathematical intelligence the
painter Picasso who was spatial
intelligence Gandhi I had an example of
interpersonal intelligence somebody who
understood other people very very well
and this got me back into the my
interest in biography and also in the
the social science interest in seeing
whether you can find some system and
extraordinary people that's really what
the book extraordinary minds
about we all many of us love to read
about the rich and the famous and the
good and the ugly and the kinds of
things they can do I mean People
magazine is sort of a late 20th century
tribute to our our fascination with
people who are unusual in one way or the
other but usually we don't search for
generalizations the endeavor that I'm
pushing in my books creating Minds
leading minds and now extraordinary
Minds is are there some underlying rules
and regulations it's as if I were a
naturalist and I discover new species
namely that tiny portion of humanity one
tenth of one hundredth of one percent
that actually changes life afterwards
Napoleon Napoleon his impact is it felt
today
and so if you take people like Napoleon
or Hitler or Gandhi in the area of
politics in the military or you take
people like Martha Graham or Virginia
Woolf or Igor Stravinsky in the area of
the arts and you say are these just
people who have no connection to one
another each of them has entirely their
own biography well either some through
lines I get some things which really run
through their lives and that's what I'm
trying to do in these studies of
extraordinary people and the other thing
I'm trying to do an extraordinary mind
is to say well most of us are not going
to be Freud and most of us are not going
to be Martha Graham but are there some
lessons which we can learn from
extraordinary people which might make us
more effective as just ordinary people
trying to have a decent life and perhaps
to make a little positive difference in
the world where did you grow up I grew
up in Scranton Pennsylvania and son of
German Jewish refugees from Nazi Germany
and probably then those shadows are
visible in my work did they survive yeah
and are they still alive still I they
live with my sister and me now in the in
Boston I don't mean in the same home but
they the whole family is now living in
Boston how are they and biography back
you know it's funny nobody no one's ever
asked me that before I think my father
has always been interested in biography
and even till this day still likes to
read and talk about people he's almost
90 my mother probably
has the deeper interest in human beings
she's he's quite a remarkable social
animal in in the town where I where they
lived for 50 years and where I grew up
she was one of the people who really
mattered in the human community and I
think it was because of an interest in
and the ability to understand other
people and to be to be helpful for them
so I guess the human dimension was
important in my growing up and I think
it turned out to be important in my
family as a whole lot of psychologists
there and I guess you don't go into
psychology unless you have some interest
in in human beings at the same time and
this is really just about me personally
I think I've always valued the distance
of looking at human beings as a social
scientist rather than say as a clinician
who was actually involved in in
day-to-day helping of people and the
kind of psychology which I've done until
very recently is what's called cognitive
psychology which means it focuses more
on thinking and problem-solving than an
effect and emotions I've been both
impressed and kind of stunned by the the
fascination and emotional intelligence
particularly due to Dan Goldman's book
of a few years ago and realized that I
was always skirting around that but I
never really went into it in the kind of
depth that he and others are are doing
now and I said until now because one of
the things I'm doing that was studying
the Holocaust something I've always been
I guess frightened of doing because it
sort of hit too close to home by
studying it it makes a little bit easier
for me but it's also yeah you can't if
you were you know if you're if you're a
child of a family who you know who was
in Nazi Germany and many of whose
members ended up being being killed
that's going to be a very charged issue
for you it's not something that you can
be too clinical about you mentioned IQ
earlier what is it IQ is a number which
is given to people because of their
performance on a test it's typically a
test which takes an hour or less usually
asks for short answers and it's based on
the assumption that everybody has a
chronological age which is clearly true
but everybody also has a mental age
which I guess in the vernacular
say is how smart you are now if you're
10 years old and you also behave like
other 10 year olds wouldn't on this test
you will have an IQ of 1 which we
multiply by 100 just for because it's
like is a rounded number and then you
have an IQ of 100 and in any population
that's what the average should be things
get interesting if you are have the
mental age of a 13-year old but you're
only 10 chronologically then the ratio
is 1 point 3 to 1
your IQ is 130 and then the other side
of the bell curve as they say if you are
chronologically 10 but you only do as
well as 7 year olds then your IQ is 70
and you are at risk for a lot of
problems in school the IQ test was
invented by a very ingenious French
psychologist named Binet people have
probably heard of the stanford-binet
test that's based upon his name Binet
was trying to predict a hundred years
ago who would have trouble in school and
so he just put together lots of items
and saw who if they did well in these
items would do well in school or did
poorly and these items would do poorly
in school and that became the IQ when I
give talks I often equipped that Binet
could have saved us all a lot of trouble
if you'd simply look at last year's
grades because last year's grades are by
far the best way of predicting how
you're going to do in school next year
but particularly in America the IQ test
has had a very long and healthy run and
I think it's because we love numbers and
the notion that we can peg people as
being so much smarter or dumber than
other people is very exciting to us and
as many viewers will know there's a lot
of effort now to produce even shorter
intelligence as many ones would just
look at brain waves and to predict from
even birth how smart you're going to be
I find all of this Anathem I and my a
lot of my my personal crusade is to his
attempts to undercut this very
simplistic notion of intelligence and if
you think about about the people who I
studied in the book extraordinary Minds
Gandhi was a very indifferent student
neither Mozart nor Virginia Woolf went
to school at all Virginia Woolf grew up
in England at the turn of century her
brothers went to Cambridge but her
parents didn't bother to send her at
school now they had an stimulating
household but they didn't go to school
Freud was a terrific student but you
know the fact that you do well
we'll probably predict that you'll be
happy in school I was happy in school
and I stayed in school so I never had a
chance to find out where I was stupid
but weren't you bad look at the world
people who are CEOs people who start
religious movements people who are good
at either getting their way or at
settling disputes the psychometric IQ I
mean how well you're doing questions
like remembering numbers backwards
that's nothing to do with it so it's a
it's a rather parochial view of what
intelligence is did you ever take an IQ
test I'm sure I did but I'm happy to say
that I don't know how I how I did on it
so you don't know what your IQ is no I
took SAT kinds of tests which er you
know I was a good a good test taker one
of my colleagues Bob Sternberg who has a
theory of intelligence says that he did
very poorly on those tests and that's
one reason why he's a poem I do have an
anecdote in this regard when I was about
13 years of age my parents had me as a
quote/unquote bright young son and
because I hadn't gone ahead didn't have
higher education themselves and hadn't
gone to school in America I didn't know
quite what to do so we drove to Hoboken
New Jersey which was a couple hours from
where I grew up in Pennsylvania he went
to Stevens Institute of Technology and I
was tested for a week it cost three or
four hundred dollars which sounds like
nothing now but it was probably like
three or four thousand dollars so they
spent a lot of time to try to figure out
how to place this kid who other people
said was bright anyway at the end of it
all they called my parents and me and
they say well you know your son's pretty
confident he could probably do most
things but his his greatest strength is
in the clerical area by which they
didn't mean that I could be a minister a
rabbi someday but rather that I was
really good at going through lists and
crossing off the numbers that didn't
belong there and I said to myself God if
this is what you get from all this
investment of time and money there ought
to be a better way of thinking about
human strength so and that's a that's a
biographical a possible key to some of
my skepticism about standard tests in
your book you have the four people you
profile but then you define them and I
want to go through that with you that
Mozart is called a master what's a
master master is somebody who works in a
domain
already exist in a society the domain is
any enterprise from being a scientist to
being a composer to being a naturalist
to being a chess player and the person's
goal as the master is to actually do the
most outstanding work in that domain
however the master Mozart is
distinguished from what I call the maker
Freud because the master does not have a
particular pressure to do things in
innovative way
Mozart was not interested in making
pieces of music which were different for
everybody else's he just wanted to write
great music and holid the genres of his
of his era
Freud went from one domain to another he
started out in philosophy he went to
medical school he did neuroanatomy he
did neurology he did a physiology he did
psychology but he always wanted to make
a mark and he finally realized the best
way to make a mark was to create his own
domain called psychoanalysis to decide
who could be a member of it to make the
rules of it and of course psychoanalysis
exists till this day and people can
still trace themselves back to Freud by
whether or not their own teacher or
analyst had been had been trained by
somebody who was trained by Freud
nowadays a lot of people say well why do
you study Freud and you know he's been
disproved that's a very narrow reading
of Freud's contribution as Auden said in
a famous poem about about Freud Freud is
really it's a whole culture it's a whole
way of thinking about the world and many
of the people who criticize Freud the
most vociferously actually engage in all
sorts of arguments which would be
inconceivable before Freud I mean Freud
was the one who talked about the
importance of early experience for our
later character Freud was the person who
talked about unconscious motivation
about doing things without knowing the
reasons why and these are contributions
which go way beyond whether a particular
description of a patient was acted or
not almost all the pioneers in domains
make initial mistakes but where a man
like Freud is so different from man like
Mozart is Freud was preoccupied with
being original with starting something
new
in frank sulloway sturms he was born to
rebel he wanted to shake things up
Darwin was the same kind of character
Einstein Mossad wasn't he just wanted to
write beautiful music but /
paradoxically masters have a perverse
effect under domain because they do
things so beautifully that it makes it
impossible for other people to do it as
well and so they actually have huge
changes in the domain because they force
people to go off in a new direction
Beethoven listened to Mozart said I
could never do that but I can do
something different so from a fairly
simplistic point of view
Mozart made eight Hoban possible and I
think that the most exquisite masters
people like George Eliot and Henry James
at the end of 19th century brought the
novel to such a high point even people
say we couldn't do this and they began
to write different kinds of literary
works the intro Spector Virginia Woolf
both um both the makers and the masters
are individuals who deal with the world
of objects in the words of the world of
symbols they create works in writing
which have effect on another people now
certainly Virginia Woolf did this as
well but Virginia Woolf like Gandhi was
a person who was most interested in the
development of the domain of human
beings I called Virginia Woolf because
she was interested in herself
I called Gandhi an influencer because he
was interested in influencing other
people now everybody knows that Virginia
Woolf wrote about her own experience as
a woman living in England early in the
century being mad manic-depressive kind
of kind of illness and so like other
writers she was um concerned with her
own autobiography but I picked Virginia
Woolf to write about because she also
introspected about what it was like to
be conscious she is one of the few
literary artists in history who really
tried to capture and succeeded in
capturing her worth the nature of
consciousness she wanted to see what it
was like to live in the moment to be a
living thinking feeling free association
stream of consciousness kind of human
being
so she was introspecting not just about
a woman's need for a room of her own a
very important thing
she was introspecting but it was like to
be to be to be conscious to be alive and
so I think she's an exquisite example of
an intro Spector could you have in
Virginia Woolf case could have been
somebody else that you could put in that
spot in your book easily when you think
about people who are in writing the
people who she's always compared with
our James Joyce and Proust but I think
she's more unusual in part because if
the fact that she's a woman and because
she not only wrote about his experience
as a woman she opened the door forever
for women's experiences to be the first
person topic of what they wrote about
this is incredible Brian but it's been
said to me and no one's ever said it to
me that it's wrong
the Virginia Woolf is the first essayist
ever who was a woman in English if she
clearly wasn't the first woman writer
and they were great women writers though
sometimes they gave themselves men's
names like George Eliot Jane Austen what
was George Eliot's really Mary Ann Evans
but Virginia Woolf was able to write
about I as a woman she was able to use
her own voice now of course half of all
the op-eds and columns and essays are by
women maybe more than half and nobody
too suddenly there's no reason why women
can't write as well or better as men but
if you've been living 75 years ago and
you've been in the Athenaeum Club in
Britain you might have said we know
women can't write essays and of course
they could they didn't because they
couldn't write in their own voice what
years did she live she was born in 1810
amis a little test going out here I
think I do know her day she was born in
1882 actually the same year as a
Stravinsky and then she killed herself
in 1941 she committed suicide after
though the war broke out and she was
very depressed had she been married yes
she was married to a man named Leonard
Woolf who survived her by 25 years who
in fact you know was a great support to
her and edited her papers and together
they had something called a Hogarth
press which has it happened printed all
of Freud and even Freud is published by
Hogarth
I think that in this day and age one
would seem to be
malpractice what if one didn't also
point out that that Virginia was
marriage was not based on sex she
discovered that she didn't enjoy sex at
least with men when she was when she was
first married so they had from all
intents and purposes a a good marriage
but not a not a marriage based on sexual
ties she clearly had some attraction to
women and most people think she may have
had one or two consummated affairs but I
think like some other extraordinary
people she probably not being very
sexual being asexual would be a
descriptive description Newton is
probably the most famous example of the
physicist Isaac Newton of someone whom
somehow the notion of sex life doesn't
seem to really blend blend very well and
in a way many people say Virginia wills
most autobiographical book is called
Orlando which is a crazy book where the
chief character oscillates between being
a man and a woman and I think one has
the feeling that Virginia Woolf saw
herself that way hey one of the one of
the characteristics of some
extraordinary people in particular
Mozart Shakespeare Keats are often used
as examples these individuals are called
to have negative capability
what negative capability means is that
rather than having a strong personality
themselves they had an incredible
ability to pick up the personalities of
individuals around them and to be able
to capture that in their works so you
read all of Shakespeare's plays and his
sonnets and you say God how could
anybody have known so much about so many
kinds of people you know military people
kings queens lawyers ordinary people and
then you said which one was Shakespeare
or you read Keats's poetry or you listen
to Mozart's music and they're not there
Beethoven is right there you know
exactly what he's like and what he
wouldn't do I think that Virginia Woolf
is one of these people who took on the
coloration of the people who she knew
who she loved whom she hated whom she
corresponded with his incredible diaries
correspondence and so on and she was she
was um she I think she had multiple
sexual identifications and while I
certainly wouldn't say the
jaudy of extraordinary people have or
not so we say that the modal
heterosexual
many of them have bisexual
identifications and a colleague of mine
Mihai csikszentmihalyi and his studies
of ordinary people extraordinary people
finds that they often go through periods
of great sexual exploration or explosion
and then periods of great asceticism and
that may relate to their work you know
when they do really deeply into their
work that's what they want that's what
they want to do and then when they
finish the work their binge is to
explore with one or more one or more
partners so the whole notion of
sexuality and extraordinariness is it's
not it's not a preoccupation of mine but
in this day and age one has to at least
touch on those issues talked about the
master Mozart the maker Freud the
introspective wolf and the influencer
Gandhi American again back to because we
talk so much about politics on this
network the American politician American
leader which of these categories would
you put him or her in well I think most
of them almost by definition are
influencers any other matters but some
of them are not very successful
influencers but of course I guess it's
much easier to aspire to want to
influence people and is to than it is to
be successful I think I think in this
century we look at our presidents
probably Franklin Roosevelt was the most
effective influencer not only for his
times quote-unquote but if we take a
look at what the Margaret Thatcher sense
one of the things people are debating
now they're debating the New Deal as
they've been debating it for many many
years I mean where do we draw the line
between government's role in things and
in private roles are any of the
political leaders here makers I think
that in fact the and this is a little
bit embarrassing to say but I think in
fact a lot of the innovations in
American public life have really been in
the public relations area I mean the
notion for example of direct mail in
figuring out exactly and focus groups
figuring out in a scientific basis as
well exactly what is it that people want
not only to make you look good but to
make your opponent look bad
and those makers are people whom we
don't even know the names of and people
like Richard vigorous names are our
encounter are mentioned here
one thing that is fascinating to
contemplate is that public relations was
actually invented in the lifetime of
people who are watching this program it
was invented by a man named Edward
Bernays in the 1920s in the United
States he was the first person to
realize that you could really manipulate
public opinion political purposes for
advertising purposes and Bearnaise was
the maiden name of Freud's wife and also
her sister of course who some people
think Freud had a relationship with and
it's it's kind of interesting to think
about
Freud's interest in the unconscious and
people not being aware of why they buy
one cigarette or one soap rather than
the other and how this went through
Edward Bernays who said you know you can
you can actually you can actually
control how people think and behave on
the basis of an understanding of your
psyche and yeah Hitler was not at all
ignorant of these kinds of things he was
a master propagandist was mr. Bernays an
extraordinary mind he may well have been
I actually met him he lived to be over
100 and so he just died a few years ago
but I I I simply don't know enough about
him to be able to know too I mean one
question one always has in his
businesses what's the difference between
somebody's own public relations and and
whether they're actually doing doing
doing doing the thinking that's involved
and we were talking about direct mail a
few moments ago there are certain names
which get through the media as the
people who are behind those ideas but if
you don't go and study they are you're
careful you don't know to what extent
somebody arrogated credit to themselves
as opposed to really being the architect
and I wouldn't want to call someone a
maker unless he or she was clearly the
architect of that of that domain now how
would you I mean if we saw you in your
laboratory and I don't even know what I
mean by your laboratory anything from an
office to wherever you're off you know
your home is how do you go about
finding what you call an extraordinary
mind physically how do you find it well
I think I would be disingenuous if if I
didn't say that I stock with people who
interest me and who fascinate me
sometimes in terms of pathology
sometimes in terms of of my actual
liking of them and usually the first
thing I do is I go out and I read some
biographies to see whether there's
enough information on these people and
also whether my yeah Edward Bernays is a
good example whether one pokes around a
bit one finds out that in fact he
actually was the person who was doing it
or there were somebody else his wife for
all I know who was actually the the
mastermind so to speak and you know I've
devoted quite a bit of attention to
people before finally deciding that I
wasn't going to look at them Reagan was
somebody who I thought I would write
about and writing about Margaret
Thatcher because I came to the
conclusion that the sober speech there
was more Thatcher there than there was
Reagan there there's probably 20 times
as much stuff written about Reagan but I
don't feel that he was extraordinary as
I've come to feel that Margaret Thatcher
was in part for what we're talking about
I mean Reagan in many ways was the
product of a tremendous amount of spin
first from very wealthy Californians who
picked him up in the 50s and who saw him
as a wonderful spokesman for certain
conservative ideas at a time Lee was
probably still a Democrat but then also
the you know the masterful people in the
White House who scripted every moment of
what he did and so it with Margaret
Thatcher when one has the feeling knew
she was calling the shots um after I've
made a commitment to just to study
somebody for the purpose of writing a
book I then first read the secondary
sources and then I read the primary
sources I met their speeches or their
autobiographies or their interviews I
find read as much as I can I tend to
pick people who are recent enough that
their films or videotapes Margit Martha
Graham I went to Lincoln Center and I
looked at all the videos they had of her
and I borrowed ones from friends and
songs 40s Ally and somebody else who I
wrote about getting the early editions
of his works and the revisions and so on
was very important in fact carrying
around in my briefcase today a new book
of his juvenilia most of which was never
published it just came out in that
97 that wasn't available at the time but
it's that kind of stuff which allows me
to go beyond sort of the the public
record but and the work is only half
over when I've done the biography and
often the biography strikes people as
being a fairly familiar one if they know
a lot about the person the real work
begins when I try to look for patterns
and parallels which go across
individuals and that is a hypothesis
generation and checking process I mean I
use a simple example how many people had
one or more parents who died when they
were young I mean that's an easy thing
to count and you can see whether that's
a factor or not how many people grew up
in a small town and then moved to a big
city those are easy things to measure on
the other hand when I studied leaders
one of the questions was were they good
storytellers that's a harder thing to
study and you have to pay a lot of
attention to how are the people that
time listen to them you know
lincoln-douglas kinds of reportage tells
you a lot about the you know the ability
of people to hold the attention of
others the extent to which they relied
on speech writers stuff like that in the
back of leading mind which is my book
that came out in 1995 I decide to lay
out all my data so I've got about 50
pages of appendices where I take the
people whom I studied and I actually
show all of the evidence for each of the
claims I've making and that was done
because I think I see myself as
developing a method for studying
extraordinary nests and an extraordinary
minds I say I think we are at the
beginning of a science of extraordinary
Ness let me use one example because it's
a fun example I put forth a portrait in
the book of the the exemplary creative
type and of the exemplary leader type
maker and an influencer and I wanted
that publicly and somebody came up to me
and said you know I think of somebody
who was actually refutation of
everything you said this is this tends
to get one's attention right and in fact
the person said I think that Ludwig
Wittgenstein the Viennese philosopher
who has an exception to what you said so
I said why don't I buy between Stein
I'll spend some time reading about him
and so I spent some time reading about
him and I discovered that in some ways
he fit the pattern in some ways he
didn't and that was helpful to me
because I'm trying to build it there
so it has to be able to account for the
exceptions is rather rather than the
rules but the interesting thing about
Wittgenstein was this typically the
extraordinary people whom I met was sort
of born in the on the periphery in the
boondocks so to speak but as soon as
they were young and growing up and had a
chance to go to the city they did and
they met other people like them and they
sort of made common cause as Young Turks
Vic and Stein was born right in the
center of things his home was Salone in
Vienna where all the greats gathered so
he didn't have to move but what happened
as soon as he grew up we got this far
away from Vienna's he could never went
back to Norway went to England and so on
so I then realized that what were you
really need to do when you turn 18 or 20
is you need to get away from where you
were so if you were in the periphery you
want to go to the center he wants anyone
I got proof II I'm carrying around in my
beliefs a wonderful biography of Darwin
by Janet Janet Browne
Darwin is Vidkun genetic Darwin grew up
in England in London early in the 19th
century he knew everybody
his family was at least as central it
was wedg woods Darwin's you know really
the establishment of Britain what did
Darwin do as soon as you go up he goes
in the Beagle for five years he goes on
a boat he goes to places nobody's ever
been to do he's getting away
so when gardner starts out he says
extraordinary people you know tend to
come from the periphery and then they go
to the center they meet others but now i
can say something that i think is a
better generalization which is
extraordinary people grow up in one kind
of environment and then they need to
shake the cobwebs out and go to a very
different kind of place are you born
differently in your mom in other words
our minds different when people were
born and and can you grow a mind or are
you given something at birth that you
know is different than everybody else
I'm not asking that very well I think
you know it's a favorite question for
all of us in this business I think when
it tough when you talk about people who
are highly intelligence intelligent in
an area like people are highly
linguistic intelligence or highly
musically intelligent they probably have
a nervous system which is that promise
for being very very good it promise
means simply
that if you take a hundred people you
teach them all to play chess some of
them can be winning steadily some are
gonna be losing steadily because some
people have better nervous systems for
learning whatever it is to take to be
good in chess as soon as you move though
from just being good into something
being good in something to being
creative or to being a leader and
basically the people who I'm studying
are either people who are creative in a
domain or trying to influence other
people
I think biology doesn't get you very far
I think these people are made they're
made by an infinite number of factors
which means you can't let me decide I
want to make my kid into a creative
person or I'm gonna make my kid into a
leader however there are all sorts of
things you can do to prevent that from
happening and I'm interested in the
preventive things as well as the
facility things but I know this
literature as well as anybody which is
only to say that not many people have
asked the question about the brains or
the genes of extraordinary people and I
just don't think there's any credible
evidence that people who eventually
change domains are different from people
who don't I do think there's credible
evidence that people learn to master a
domain very quickly have different
brains than those who don't
mozart's brain is not the same as mine
alas for me the actual book is a hundred
and sixty-one pages how did you keep it
so short I think that um when you know
something very well and you say here's
my chance to really bring it to a new
state of readiness the book almost
writes itself another way of putting it
is let's say I was writing a book about
Napoleon
I would probably my first draft would
have to be a thousand pages because I
was getting to know about Napoleon
there's so much to do if I've been
spending a lifetime studying Napoleon
the way say David Donald has spent a
lifetime studying Lincoln you really
know what the the high points are the
summits what not only the most important
things to say but the most important
things to say at this historical moment
given whatever with what is on everybody
else's mind
so if except one can I talked a lot
about in extraordinary minds is why do
we have so much antipathy nowadays
toward heroes why are we made
uncomfortable by people who are seen as
extraordinary why is it seen as being
politically incorrect fifty years ago
when so many books are written in the
spirit that's not a point that I would
four separated on so I think it's it's
both having a I guess I'll say command
of your subject and having a command of
a moment which I think enables you to
write a short book I mean there's a
there's a phrase which has been
attributed everybody I was attributed to
Voltaire it is if I had a time enough
I'd be brief and in this sense I've had
20 or 25 years to draw on this and so I
can be much more synthetic and summative
than if I was writing my first book
about extraordinary people our guest has
been Harry Gardner a professor at
Harvard and the title of the book is
extraordinary minds and it's one of the
last of the basic books thank you very
much for joining us thank you